hello everyone and welcome to what's
next in kubernetes
i'm bob killen a program manager within
google's open source programs office
also a long time contributor to the open
source kubernetes project and i'm here
to talk a little bit about some of the
overarching future paths for kubernetes
but before i can dig into what's next
i need to talk a little about where
we've been
what it's taken for kubernetes to become
the foundational platform that powers so
much today
from a high level you can sort of break
down kubernetes phases into three broad
layers
that highlight a focus or theme in the
project's life cycle
the first and the longest was four years
from june 2014 to march 2018.
this is a period of rapid growth where
all the various resource types are being
defined and solidified
these
are the base components that are used by
everything else
think of the core workloads such as
deployments stateful sets and all the
others
these core workloads graduated to ga in
the 1.9 release
and was shortly thereafter
recognized by the cloud native competing
foundation's technical oversight
committee approving the project for
graduation
kubernetes was the first project to
achieve the status
it was recognized for being stable
used by a number of companies having a
diverse contributor base and solid
project governance
this is the foundational stage and every
future thing is built on top of it
the second phase from march 2018 to
september 2019 is marked by the
graduation of custom resource
definitions or crds
a unified pattern to extend kubernetes
it created an entire ecosystem allowing
people projects and organizations to
create and manage their own applications
in any other
sort of kubernetes resource
instead of managing these deployments
you can now directly manage things like
a database or a game server in a
kubernetes native way
it was huge for the cloud native
landscape
and if you look at the cncf with its
hundred or so projects you'll find that
the majority of them are using crds
this last phase from late 2019 to august
2020
isn't noted by a new feature but a shift
in the mentality of the project
we built our core workload types we've
made the project easy to extend
and now with more users than ever using
the project we shifted to supportability
and stability
policies and processes were put in place
to help ensure
every feature being developed was
observable scalable could be rolled back
and a slew of other
important things for general operations
and in doing so we were more comfortable
expanding our support window
with new releases being supported for a
full year
we built our core
we made it easy to extend
and integrate with
and then committed ourselves to a
stronger support policy
so that takes us to now and where we're
going
and i'll keep the theme for this one
sort of a secret to the end
but i want to give you an idea of some
of the features and areas of where we're
focusing and for that i picked two big
things to follow
the first is multi-cluster
so
why multi-cluster
kubernetes has done a lot to help people
rethink and reshape their architecture
and build more resilient and scalable
systems
but for many use cases you can't just
build a larger cluster
say you want global availability and to
minimize the latency to your customers
that's something you can't easily do
with a single cluster
or you might want to scale and burst
your workloads especially in something
like a hybrid environment where you've
outgrown your on-prem hardware and want
to burst the cloud
you may also be working with privileged
or sensitive data and want to maximize
your security by using clusters as a
security boundary
or lastly you may just want to make your
application more resilient by running
multiple clusters in ha and to segment
your failure domains
the list goes on
it's often one of the first places
organizations go to after getting up and
going with a single cluster
now with that i'm going to go out a
little on a limb
but in a multi-cluster world
clusters are the new pod
as management of kubernetes clusters
becomes easier it allows you to focus on
the important parts
namely your application
clusters are becoming a tightly coupled
grouping of these app components that
you might want to scale and secure
independently
so just like a deployment manages the
pods and helps scale them up and down
and manages their life cycle you should
be able to do that with clusters too
so why has this been so hard
well
a frank multi-cluster configurations in
their current form are incredibly
complex with a lot of moving parts
if you have a database in cluster a that
should be accessible to some component
in cluster b it requires a lot of
additional plumbing of services between
clusters
often additional load balancers or a mix
of them with like a service mesh it's
not fun and by no means easy
also to be frank
kubernetes was honestly not really
designed for multi-cluster in mind
initially
but this has been long recognized by the
upstream community and there have been
several initiatives targeting and
improving this use case
the first is the introduction of
multi-cluster services
a new crd that standardizes the way in
which you can share great services
across clusters
no more additional provisioning of load
balancers no more hodgepodge custom dns
rules that require manual updating
you define a cluster set or a group of
two or more clusters and decide
which services in each cluster you want
to expose and a new controller will just
take care of the rest
for your applications all you have to do
is point them to a new cluster set
service dns entry
instead of you know the regular
cluster.local one that we all are sort
of used to
and with that your traffic will be
routed appropriately
now
this is a very simple model and it was
specifically designed to be that way
to address the complexity of
cross-cluster networking and service
discovery
to make it an easy to use as a drop-in
replacement for current services
now there's a lot that goes on under the
hood
but you as a user do not need to manage
those aspects of it
so now that we have these multi-cluster
services that can help you manage your
cross-cluster networking
how about ingress
how do you manage getting
traffic into your cluster at a global
level
well there's something for that too
the gateway api
think of it as ingress version 2.0
it was designed with all the lessons
learned from the original kubernetes
ingress implementation
with many of the pain points such as
excessive use of annotations
being addressed
and for the purposes of multi-cluster
it can use the exports from the
multi-cluster services api
as a valid backend allowing you to
manage your ingresses at a global level
now for gke
these two resources have come together
to offer a very flexible and powerful
system
within gke there are two fundamental
different types of clusters
standard where you retain full control
in autopilot where much of the
management aspects are abstracted away
and managed by google
autopilot is a great option for many
workloads and comes with advantages like
better security and per pod billing
but
there are some workloads that you know
don't necessarily lend
itself to it well
namely you know large stateful
applications
or things where you may need to run in a
pod in privileged mode
but that's where multi-cluster comes in
what if we can interconnect and deploy
apps where they fit best without having
to worry about the plumbing
you'd be able to take advantage of the
greater security and per pod billing for
most resources in autopilot and retain
the greater control over just the parts
of your stack that need it
in a standard cluster while honestly
managing them in a
dramatically easier way
and that's part of the future we're
working towards
so now that we've covered multi-cluster
let's take a look at the next focus area
and that's in the area of ai ml and
batch computing
now
this is an area that's actually near and
dear to my heart before i started at
google i was heavily involved in
research computing and exploring
kubernetes for high performance
computing needs
and while there have been advances in
what i'll say broadly as research
computing on top of kubernetes
there has generally been a much slower
rate of adoption
of it versus i'll say more traditional
applications
and
that's because it's hard for a number of
reasons
first and foremost the kubernetes
scheduler is built for bin packing or
trying to cram as much on a single node
as possible which tends to go against
most really resource intensive jobs
it also doesn't support the concept of
co-scheduling where you block scheduling
until there's enough resources available
to run your entire job
the other thing is most of these
research applications also require a lot
of tuning the application
the underlying system or host os
and also things like the api server if
you're spinning up
you know hundreds of thousands of tasks
you need everything to be working at
peak performance
and to be able to handle
that sort of scale
now
there are a few things coming in the
pipes to help improve this
but i want to focus on one thing that
has been an open request for a very long
time
and will help reduce the complexity of
work cues
work cues are fairly simple in concept
they're a list of tasks or data intended
to be processed by one or more workers
they are by far the most common work
pattern seen in ai ml and batch
you're providing a data set and
iterating over it in a pair in parallel
for training or processing
and kubernetes has not really supported
this workflow natively it's always
required some other external system such
as pub sub to keep track of what's being
processed
this also means that you must bake in
more sort of like middleware logic into
your job just to be able to process it
you know it works organizations have
been using this pattern since jobs are a
thing in kubernetes
but do you really want to do that
or would you rather rely on something
that could be done
natively
i'd pick the latter
so
in kubernetes 1.21
a new alpha feature was added to jobs a
completion mode
or if you specify it as indexed each pod
is given a numbered identifier with the
index starting at zero
this index will be used in the
generation of the pods hostnames giving
it something predictable akin to
stateful sets
that index is also passed into the pod
as an environment variable and what this
does
is it gives you the ability
a built-in native way to statically
assign data to the process
processes of each pod
it will require a little bit of planning
ahead of time
but you won't have to run an external
system you won't have to bake something
into your code for the job just to pull
items from the queue
it reduces the overall complexity of
work cues significantly and
you know this seems like a small thing
but it solves a problem for a lot of
people
in addition to this there are also
several other things in the works
that will enable or ai ml and batch
types of workloads
things like the scheduler framework
where instead of trying to make the
kubernetes scheduler be everything to
everyone
many more hooks and methods of
integrating with it have been created
it's now significantly easier to extend
and customize how scheduling is done
by assigning workloads to different
scheduling profiles
jobs can also now be suspended and what
this means
is that if you say a higher party job is
to be scheduled the lower party job can
be suspended until the higher priority
job is completed it doesn't have to be
rescheduled
work can pick back up when the higher
priority job is done
something you know we've seen
in a lot of classic batch systems for
years
lastly there has been some changes to
the creamery's api server
so it can be tuned to support the
exceedingly high throughput of requests
that often come in with batch job
oriented systems
and all these things combined will make
running
ai ml and batch workloads significantly
easier on top of kubernetes
and
at this point with that sort of you know
short preview of the improvements to
things like multi-cluster
and aiml and batch
you may have started to pick up on a
theme
what is kubernetes
kubernetes is foundational
we spent four years building a strong
base
all the core workloads and design
patterns that you depend on today
started here
is extensible
a year and a half were spent making it
easy for people to adopt build and
extend on that foundation
creating an ecosystem
that is just absolutely massive today
kubernetes is mature
we put a lot of effort into making sure
you can depend on every feature and
every release
and we demonstrated this by extending
our support window
so
what is kubernetes now
is it easy
well we're not there yet
we're making it
easier for you to use
we're reducing much of the complexity
that has forced people into workarounds
in building our out large more complex
systems
a lot of these features and improvements
may seem minor at first look
but all of them are there to help
improve the various workflows that
people have built around and on top of
kubernetes
and as we make queries easier for people
to use
it will also enable a whole new set of
use cases that we haven't imagined yet
so kubernetes isn't easy
yet
but we'll get there
and
that if you are interested in learning
more about some of the stuff i talked
about today
here are some additional resources that
you might find useful in particular i
want to highlight the learn kubernetes
with google video series you'll find
videos going over how you can get going
with multi-cluster index jobs and quite
a bit more
thank you and i look forward to building
the future of kubernetes with you